yeah welcome to yet another keep it sing
video and I managed to manage damn well
I was online and seeing that John I'm
sorry we can a good match up here
between the reigning US Champion
Karuna camera and the reigning Russian
champion um Dmitry and awakened so yeah
well this is like them
yeah the small version of Fischer was
the Spassky of today's having a blitz on
the SSE yeah what we get here is some
Sicilian position now camera playing
black this some started as a Sicilian
con with e6 and a 6 but transposed the
position type at least them into
something you very often get in them
so-called Kalashnikov variation with 96
and E 5 well Black has this e5 d6 pawn
structure but he doesn't have them dark
square Bishop this is exchanged so
structurally black is white okay and now
we've got ya full scale simplification
going grab like him yes c5 no I guess it
was nice structurally but like somewhat
like time question is if you will get
the pawn back the pressure on the D pawn
is now annoying somehow I'm I think
maybe 94 was mistimed don't know it
what's happening very quickly
yeah now white will just have an extra
pawn on d6 and difficult for black to to
get it back especially considering that
the rest of the pawns are all we got so
yeah so night on before might be an idea
yeah now before 93 now is maybe
man-on-man in general 93 is a good idea
to attack me five
not sure if it's working now technically
because 95 is checked no also f4 was
interesting but now these 70 others
looks very grim for black Kamloops for
six black reason yes yeah this was a
pretty pretty strong player yes okay now
we have a birds opening 1f form played
by nakamura and black played the from--
from I think gambit the most aggressive
answer would be five so um yeah quite a
messy position
yeah Queens I exchanged whites got the
bishop pair in an extra pawn but then
the five pawn is hard to keep white
tries to play for night night be 595 but
blankets and equipped long castles can't
think black will get the pawn back and
it should be okay so white um just have
the two bishops it should be three of
surprises me that GM gives up the bishop
so so easily
yeah black can just take f4 d3 and
should be fine I would say Jack Jack
black him just take them to now yeah I
don't know like just his neck strap on
g3 is also surprising to me but okay
this pawn might might be a might be a
dangerous son Jack asset at some point
of course she'll get the Jeep horn or
the g2 upon your very okay of this
leaflet so g3 is a possible Trump but it
can also be a weakness yeah 93 I think
was threatened so then only to cover a
form King f3 or something King III yeah
by the way the time control is some you
don't see it yet rather you don't see it
the time control is 3 1 so 3 minutes and
1 second increment so so we don't have
we won't have those very young silly
kind of hacking contests at the end with
playing on time white resigns yeah this
was rather yet game by white so I'm
gonna rake in here just just in the lead
didn't see the first game let me just
quickly check yeah it's um two and a
half one and a half in favor of
the Russian champion at the moment yeah
we had the same structure like in the
game before with black having um yeah
the the good bishop only six versus the
rather oops wait resign I was just
explaining the structure and to blunder
to piece and one move all right
this happens okay so we had to have the
trump offski opening let's see what we
get him yeah completely non theoretical
position they were just 94 takes on c5
yeah black short term should be okay
doesn't have any problems with them
developing pieces yeah some of them
connections are not great today I don't
think the cameras really spending 30
seconds here or 20 seconds can't believe
that just tonight just this should be
too I really spend so long
wow this is weird yeah you don't know
maybe grabbing some beverage or
something you do you never know
sometimes you have those we had kind of
time on time management things which are
just related to some other things than
chess all right so it's a bit weird
with this double G double F pawn here
after G takes a three so likes position
look
fairly solid to me not really sure what
white is playing for are directly at one
c7 but just rook c8 looks like normal
reply maybe he wants to get the night
reform but black could play e5 here
actually yeah why not a five and then
yeah a 6 e 5 bishop moves a six and
white is so yeah just drawing just
retreating pieces Oh something entirely
different
I wouldn't have thought of this one in a
million years I guess okay yeah the
night only four is quite quite strangely
plays but it's not so bad it puts some
pressure on the B troop on Queen b6
maybe maybe Queen b6 b3 and then you can
second series maybe possible b3 it takes
on c3 Queen takes 94 like maybe winning
after b3 and how does he cover the b2
porn I'm not sure a black can play e5
all the time I don't know I would have
played this but
yeah and then maybe tea form
opening up the position yeah against
them against white skin yeah White's
position looks very shaky like I'm more
eyes playing a bit weird jump like an
maybe simply take this Russia and put
put a rock on the C file or something
yeah Roxy - yeah white is just not not
very well coordinated King position is
also shaky so black is really really
doing fine but it's not um not concrete
yet yeah it doesn't have any extra
material or something's got the deep
bone and the better structure and see
far our queen d5 or something okay just
grabbed another pawn yeah this is maybe
some crowd to play check yeah but
it's pieces are simply not not active
enough the dip on some real nuisance
maybe just roti eight I tries to play it
safe in a way returning the spawn but
yeah at the end does the BND a porn and
he will just push this helm I guess yeah
the a porn is really a the decider here
if you've got the g7 Bishop you you
usually promote the pawn white resigns
yeah yeah the camera is not it's not
doing well really what you would expect
her more in a way okay we got the same
opening again at last time Nakamura
actually won because under a complete
London piece and one move
yeah again we have the structure where I
was trying to explain that like looks
nice with a good bishop only six and
white bishop on these fries not so great
but the problem is that you don't have
any corn breaks claimed like you cannot
really well you will never move your
deep on f5 is hard to play and b5 also
difficult this wide control to this
point so black is in a way are sitting
on a nice structure but he cannot
improve so much and this is what white
is playing for that down the structure
in the long run is favorable for him
yeah the Queen exchange should should
actually help like you can try to defend
d6 with king of 87 and so on and if you
get some pieces exchanged then I would
be should be forth and is good okay it's
not a big deal I thought the pawn
structure could be a problem but this is
fairly solid for white now we can pile
up on the D pawn yeah King is seven
covers rather comfortably but you see
that um while black looks okay it's hard
to make any progress yeah white rice
maybe to get the knight or f5 or this
one okay
yeah another bad idea and he tries to 96
maybe young I'm not sure what what black
is doing is so great he tries to play
active who's with g6 and so on but um
just my opinion that's not adjusted
obviously Nakamura as the better player
I was more thinking of yeah keeping the
position as is so to say it doesn't look
good to me that black has any meaningful
ways to to do something active can ever
really play h5 because of g5 and what
are you doing on the Kings side well
really I thought g5 would shock a g5 is
also porn weakness for white so it's not
clear-cut yeah I see that but maybe f4
yeah f4 now takes and rook t5 something
like this but this is a fight again it's
an interesting interesting claim it's
not a dead position or something
ha see find who interesting Chuck Chuck
so um it has--that's pretty much changed
white broke through in the center but
black has got the very dangerous age
pawn jammed entered this free porn this
past pawn should be em should be really
sorry Lee problems on white yeah now c5
fault
okay white right desperation sacrifice
yeah that should be shouldn't it be
winning okay white gets the King to g7
maybe even hmm
King f6 yeah
and King g7 imagine three and then King
g7 I had a look at one trick yeah okay
hmm shouldn't it should be winning right
upside he actually got a knight how did
he do that so quickly this is cool this
the Sunday under promotion if this is a
correct word in English yes a whiter
fights on with with this new newly poor
night check
yeah actually if I would have this in a
game and I need to promote tonight I
didn't I I think I wouldn't I wouldn't
even managed to switch this off so
quickly the alter promote to Queen yeah
okay what is this position why it's got
the palm for the exchange but blacks got
the Jeep on it should suddenly be
winning for black but itself maybe it's
still slightly tricky white am white
will use the upon them so one of those
position where you know i well that damn
job with perfect play you certainly
winning but it's um it's easy to to miss
something or maybe this is the yeah this
just looks like a clean way maybe just
return the exchange when you seek should
be a winning king opponent game yeah
right
huh yes this is winning with the g porn
you get all the queenside pawns yeah
nicely done
technically i hope you got more games
this delay is not good yeah very nice
you move here ff8 check f8 night this is
cool jack oops sorry yeah and at the end
the king opponent game is some is
winning king takes King e6 and then you
move the G pawn and more White's King
needs to attend to this pawn you get the
Queen side it's very helpful to have
this b7 and a 5-pound that block White's
pawns
yeah
no game no game sorry
not sure what's what's happening
I can try quickly - yeah they're both
the salon yeah
can be anything just small break for the
restroom or something I'll wait down a
minute or so if uh yeah here they go
again
nice so g3u for a change huh transposing
- yeah sort of Leningrad Dutch reversed
I think this is also sometimes called
the polar bear Grandmaster Henrik done
Yeltsin made a couple of very nice
YouTube videos about this opening it's
got huge success with it yeah well
what's basic ideas to play an e form at
some point yeah exactly now to get some
center it's got a nice Center really
it's only am i no white piece position
looks a bit uncoordinated with a knight
on h4 and queen he won't look everyone
so the rook is checked on f1 chatter
yeah Knight g4 hmm yeah you rarely see a
look on e3 so early in the game black
will win the exchange of course it's um
still somewhat
yeah somewhat messy I guess but then it
should suddenly be just an exchange
maybe black and play Bishop d3 here yeah
what do we add trend with transformation
now White has this strange setup here on
the on the kingside yeah it should just
be losing really yeah White's position
is just just not harmonious at all the
knight on a three and you are really
really full of weaknesses here maybe
even Bishop d1 yup likes got everything
lastly under control just root dat white
resigns yeah
also this b3 Bishop was covering of
seven so any kind of hope was somewhat
distinguished extinguished by this
Bishop so yes something different now
whoops black resigns this was a pre move
but 96 was okay I think we need five to
come yeah I think nothing worse but now
somewhat done I know the angry at
himself I don't know we didn't really do
much good in this match up to now
yeah this kind of position quite often
arises in this some Sicilian on lines
like the term an orphan town
yeah this is exactly what I was trying
to say that white often attacks it was
see form and tries to provoke like into
moving the deep on after this by default
bad here but then the center would be
closed and white might have chances to
to play with the F pawn on trying to use
her some three to two on the queenside
it didn't happen though we played them
Bishop f4 not aged five and now black
wrap the bishop am and just a five now
yeah white can still try with before a
form and so on
using this three two two on the Queen
side okay is some heading for something
else I guess yeah here here not f3 to d3
would be a nice maneuver the knight
would be very nice on d3 covering be to
covering c5 and then you might play f4
in the long run so you definitely play
91 now nighty you want to D three okay
he doesn't do it but now yeah I like
this for white knight on d3 is very nice
really keeping everything nicely
together on the Queen side and
supporting f4 this is why I was a bit
curious about the Ruby see one move
because I thought f4 was the idea and
why not have to look on f-14 from maybe
you put it back now yeah
yeah just look at three work everyone
yeah why does certain define here should
be should have a good position jack
white reasons he overlooked this shot
this was so quickly the resigns rook
edge one King edge one between HP check
so yeah don't know maybe Nakamura
playing too quickly too many pre moves
yeah this was so quickly maybe you want
to rewind the video it watch it in
slow-mo
okay slightly different setup yeah what
doesn't castlelong unfortunately would
be it would be fun to see so we got the
same structure again I don't know so as
mentioned very solid for black but he
cannot do much yeah I wonder why he's
playing this all the time not that it is
bad but he Nakamura usually who tries to
yeah go for from more active position so
white is just blundered he for this must
be helpful but at least the the bishop
won't be one let's cut some scope now
it's still not super easy for black oh
now he gets yeah he gets in d5 alright
yeah this is a pawn now I mean it was a
pawn before but my I mean just to clear
extra pawn white has got no compensation
I guess
yeah maybe some some strengthening move
on the kingside like g6 at some point or
maybe Queen d2 we am Queen d2 getting
the Queen's off white cannot really
avoid this Jack Jack Oh black gets all
pieces now I am it's it's still slightly
tricky for black considering the time
you need to make sure that everything's
okay this this should be okay now you
can now play on the Queen side only and
yeah on the King side of course on the
Queen side you can just coordinate your
pieces now on the Kings side and
probably we win one of those pawns let's
say rook to c4 and then try to get the
Knight to f5 would win the edge pawn
something along these lines would be
would be a plan you know he's going for
this I get something right and now off
to to f5 but f5 is not easy to to reach
with a knight
yeah what sunlight you to f4 or
something
yeah everything's nicely protected yeah
I think it's funny how much time they
have have left I actually think that
they're playing a quick to farm one once
in a while a quick two took far too
quickly I mean and this also has led to
some rather big blunders I mean they
start with three minutes and a camera
has got 220 left of course you get the
bonus seconds and increments but it
still feels like you've like terribly
quickly quite resigned
yeah no dream phone gets lost or black
enters yeah no camera now going from
more mainstream kind of lines
he tried some weird Queenie to stuff
before me and of this this kind of
Queenie too but like if rc5 Queenie -
and now we have sort of reversed roles
um just the sea ponies on sea - yeah no
yeah this is some similar to the
positions before but now black has got
them the bishop on a 7 which is
unopposed by a white bishop so black Ham
has gone turned the bishop pair oh this
is interesting
should this be ok for black if you just
take it on d5 with
the bishop and then play f5 something
like this yeah all this to d7 and then
f5 young someone is some listening the
score here and Reagan is leading by two
six and a half to four and a half yeah
white immediately tries to break this
central advance here with f3 and now if
you have this funny pawn on e3 it so
nicely supported by the bishop and now
also with the queen question is some can
black somehow benefit from this pawn
hard to see at the moment hope like what
make any direct progress ok the queen is
not the most brilliant term locating
piece but it's doing its job at the
moment yeah black somehow needs to yeah
get into White's position to dislodge
the locating piece like the Queen here
and yeah there are only two ways to do
that on the Queen side with b5 what you
tried I'm going for something like g5
okay grab this a4 pawn this is
interesting
and now he tries to get get to d5 but
white covered this with c4
yeah I'm not sure I think black is
making some progress here on the on the
queenside
and defy f is also hanging yeah you've
got to be pawn okay but now blacks got
the e pawn and the D pawn it looks
dangerous
and also Roxy - maybe
yeah whoopsie - what should why do you
have to seem rhymes now you just grab
grab small prawns yeah like it's just
winning it seems maybe II - no II -
cannot take with the bishop the Queen on
b7 is saying I'm Bishop c4 check out
what everyone is hanging
I wish up c4 maybe I just rope shakes of
course and everyone is saying with made
nonsense yeah then this is this should
win really so oops what's happening how
white what the hell is happening here
wow what cannot take because of wins and
now yeah Ruby a troop yet this is great
am i resigned yeah he nicely he nicely
won this one nice finish with ropes e8
yes um
long theoretical set up here with Bishop
III 92 okay I need to do something once
in a while it's still it's still hot
here some approaching close to 10 p.m.
here but it doesn't help much still hot
okay so um we got into a pawn structure
more typical of the French defense with
this e65 pawn I think black should be
fairly okay here you also have the idea
of Bishop b5 maybe at some point to
exchange your bishop okay it's just
playing for g5 which has become a fairly
topical idea in the French to push your
flank pawns undermining in a way the e5
pawn so preventing f4 making a far more
problematic whoa nice shot if black
takes then it's a six and it will get
hairy that's nice
yeah Nakamura actually just keep its
tier
and he says always annoying when you
play someone who treats blitz like it's
the World Championship and place the
same opening over and over again so yeah
there's always two to tango in a way
yeah White's got gotten us very strong
attack here rope is hanging and Bishop
f6 it looks very dangerous i adult knock
signs he had looks dangerous Bishop f6
yeah a new came yes equi - and you got a
different opening yeah not terribly a
great one maybe but yeah I think they
had this before and in the one game
before I started to to cover this on
video they had this line before with c4
yeah why - suddenly am I not in great
shape here 93 already threatened
yeah maybe just 93 yeah this doesn't
look better also
yeah okay but if you play 93 now maybe
it doesn't lead to much Qing f1 and how
do you protect the e4 pawn I don't know
yeah he six is very better intending
Bishop c5 yeah Bishop c5 looks good
maybe he can play 92 actually to play
Knight d5 black plays Bishop c5
otherwise this would really be a threat
so something like Age 3 year you get you
get this Bishop c5 in
maybe black can take on c4 now night c4
Queen d1 check he could win you one yeah
and queen d3
yeah well knock and Morris complaint as
yeah you can sing whatever you want
black is just him under 18 is just
taking this match seriously and wants to
wants to win and place with Frank so to
say and down well he he really needs to
yeah gif is very best to to stay on the
board and the Mammootty doesn't really
manage he also good like him has got
pretty big advantage already I would say
it just got he's got an extra pawn and
yeah look at White's pieces they look
they don't look very well coordinated
yeah
you should be - yeah it's a big threat
you should be to rupee one Bishop take C
- yeah just e - now
Queenie - yeah black and just take it -
I'm not sure what he's doing okay maybe
some swindling chances Quincy five maybe
Quincy five you need to go to d7 so yeah
it still should be winning somehow but
it looks a bit a bit shaky cry yeah how
do you play for window King e7 Bishop c5
he would need to play rock d6
yeah somehow somehow he drummed up a
little bit of play here yeah he's some
down down by four games four points well
this is a mess
I can also take on b7
well yet another myth queen somewhere
yeah and then takes a piece of yeah I
have no idea what's going on rook b8
maybe something like this but what I
wouldn't mess
what's Queenie saying black squid is
hanging everything saying yeah now Queen
takes and you maybe get your pieces
coordinated again yeah white really get
really got some something going here but
maybe now you should t4 we should be for
maybe looking for
yeah maybe black and play for win this
endgame but it's tricky
yes also the F porn
now this is starting to look nice for
black now the upon maybe can be can be a
winner white rocks are are looking
somehow misplaced yeah this is final for
black III coming
III 94 stuff like this white resigned
yeah yeah this is this is all is really
really close to lost yeah
plus this was plus five at the end for
form and Reagan so the Russian sham won
by five points against Nakamura who
didn't have a good day and it seems
yeah well the matches oval a camera has
left the server so yeah thanks for
watching I think some pretty spectacular
games um let's talk soon with new videos